foreign
okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others and let's see it
looks like we have some
questions left over from
uh previous time so i can maybe start
off with these there's a question from
keyboard92 can data be sent
via light wirelessly
so uh the answer is yes
um the uh okay
one very common way that data is sent
by via light is in fiber optics but
let's first of all talk about
what it means to send data somewhere
so what is data data is uh
the video that that i'm transmitting
here the audio that i'm transmitting
here
the text that you send from some place
to some place
the first important thing to realize is
that all of those things
in the end are just sequences of ones
and zeros
all of those things whether it's a
sequence of characters in a piece of
text
an a is represented by some sequence of
ones and zeros
uh eight ones and zeros uh a b is
represented by a different sequence of
ones and zeros
when we're sending audio for example
what we're sending is the
the intensity of sound as it changes
with time that's what uh as i'm
as i'm talking i'm uh i'm producing
different vibrations in the air that's
what turns into the sound wave that's
what we get to transmit
all of these things are ultimately can
be thought of as let's say sequences of
numbers
in the end sequences of bits on or off
one or zero so what we have to do when
we send
data is we've got to do something where
we can
transmit the knowledge that it's a one
or it's a zero
so the most common way to do that is
through electrical wires
where it's like either there is a
a voltage either there are electrons
being pushed at that moment in time or
they're not
um and that can happen the uh the the
are you seeing a a is there a each bit
might take a um uh as little as a
let's say a billionth of a second to be
um
uh to be transmitted and for that
billionth of a second
is there a voltage is there not a
voltage that's what determines
uh whether there's a one or a zero at
that particular position
so when we think about doing this uh
wirelessly what we're talking about is
sending
that information through radio for
example
and uh when we're transmitting things
through radio
what's happening is that that we have a
radio transmitter
that's either sending a one at a
particular time or sending a zero at a
particular time and we have a receiver
that's uh that's responding to that and
that's
seeing whether the the in that
particular case electromagnetic wave
um had uh uh was
whether there was a piece of
electromagnetic wave at that moment in
time or there wasn't
and let's say a billion times a second
it's um uh it's either there is it is
there or it isn't there and that's where
the
the one or the zero ends up being
transmitted
now uh the the most common way
to transmit things wirelessly
is through traditional wireless which is
radio
which is electromagnetic waves um where
what you're doing is you have an antenna
which has uh an electric
uh current that's kind of oscillating in
the antenna that's producing
this uh this electromagnetic waves that
goes through
free space it can go through vacuum it
can go through air
it can go through other materials that
don't absorb it
um and and then it's getting at the
other end
the receiver is also the electromagnetic
wave comes in
and it causes the electrons to kind of
wiggle around in the receiver
and that shows up as an as a electric
current or like a
a voltage and so on that can be detected
okay so that's kind of that approach
now can you do the same kind of thing uh
with light
well light is just among other things
another kind of electron
another electromagnetic wave radio might
be an electromagnetic wave
where fundamentally the wave is wiggling
up and down
a billion times a second light is more
like a wave
electromagnetic wave where things are
wiggling up and down a trillion times a
second
um now how do you so so the idea of how
you transmit the ones and zeros it's
like
the light is on the light is off at
different times
um uh you know if you want to make
something which
transmits you know one one zero zero or
some one one zero zero one
it will be the light is on on off off on
okay
so so how does that work well
uh one of the questions is where
can you uh where can you
use how can you transmit things through
light
well light typically goes in straight
lines
so if you want to transmit something uh
a signal by using let's say a laser
you can have a transmitter where the
laser is
is where you're many times a second
you're you're switching laser on or off
um there are good ways to do that there
are materials called
electro-optic materials where when you
put a voltage through the material
it will um uh it will um
uh be able to let light through and if
you don't it can't or the other way
around
that's how like liquid crystal displays
are related to that
i mean okay so a little side side
uh side adventure what is a liquid
crystal display
um there are two main kinds of displays
that get used for
for laptops and things these days liquid
crystal displays
and uh light emitting diode displays i'm
going to talk about liquid crystal
displays
um in liquid crystal so what is a
crystal a crystal is a
is a solid material where all the atoms
are lined up in a very organized way
um that's that's what a crystal is a
liquid crystal
is something where you have big long
molecules and the positions of the
molecules are not lined up like they are
in an ordinary crystal
the position of the molecules aren't
lined up but their directions are lined
up so they're big long molecules
and in a liquid crystal when the thing
is
what you have is a bunch of these these
molecules where the positions
are kind of all over the place but
they're all lined up in one direction
and the reason that's relevant is that
when all these molecules line up in one
direction
it kind of makes uh light able
only uh what well it
it polarizes light so what what that
means is
light normally you can have an
electromagnetic wave if the
electromagnetic wave is coming towards
you
the electromagnetic wave can be kind of
um uh having
uh can be kind of wiggling either up or
down or left or right or any combination
of those
but if you force the electromagnetic
wave to go through this kind of little
mesh of molecules
you're forcing it to only be able to
wiggle up and down not to be able to
wiggle left and right
and that's and so the way lcd displays
work is does
you know for example as a backlight in
your computer display which is just an
ordinary
just an ordinary light and what's
happened is the computer display
already has uh one polarizer that is
kind of oriented let's say in the up
down direction so light is only getting
through from the backlight
when the light is polarized is is is
moving up and down this way
then the liquid crystal is is uh
is set up so that when the liquid
crystal
if there's a voltage put on the liquid
crystal all those molecules line up it
makes the style of crystalline state
and it makes the crystalline state where
the it is
uh let's say set up to be aligned so the
crystal so that the um
uh the the sort of the the mesh is going
the other way
so that means light if if there's a
place on your screen
where light was coming through from the
back light it was wiggling up and down
and there wasn't a piece of liquid
crystal in front of it
that was was was sort of set up to be
aligned then the light just goes through
it's all good
if on the other hand there's a piece of
liquid crystal that was set up by a
voltage
um to to line up all those molecules
then the light which was okay it's
happily wiggling up and down
but now it reaches this thing it can't
wiggle up and down anymore and so no
light goes through
and so then that pixel on your screen is
black
um so that's that's kind of how an lcd
display works
and you can change whether the molecules
are lined up or not
very quickly and that's an example of a
way it's not the most efficient way
there's a
even more efficient way to do it to to
basically switch on and off uh a light
beam okay so one of the questions then
is how do you get
the light beam to go from here to there
if you just have a laser
just pointing you know in in free space
or whatever
you're the you know you shine the laser
somewhere if there's anything in the way
you're you're out of luck so let's say
you wanted to get
a laser light to you wanted to have a
light beam
that was going to transmit information
all the way across the atlantic
well really tough to do because you'd
have to have something which is up in
space with a satellite with lasers
you know shining from one satellite to
another because if it's on the surface
of the earth it's curved
and the light will just go in a straight
line and one won't be able to deal with
that
okay there's a way around it it's called
fiber optics
and so fiber optics uh are
these um little pieces of plastic or
glass
which have um which have the property
that
inside the um a
transparent fiber and you shine a laser
in at one end of the transparent
fiber and there are often little toy
versions of this you shine a laser in at
one end or light in at one end
and even though the fiber may be may be
bent the light still comes out the other
end of the fiber
how does that work what's happening is
that
inside the fiber the light is bouncing
off the the sides of the fiber in other
words it's like having
as far as the light is concerned it's
like the the outer
side the outer part of the fiber acts
like a mirror
and so it's like light comes in at one
end and it keeps on bouncing
from these mirrors down and down and
down and down and down until eventually
the light comes out at the other end
now the really cool thing about optical
fibers is that it's been
possible to make them so that the light
will just keep going in the optical
fiber if there are no imperfections no
sort of glitches in the fiber i don't
know how long it is these days but
hundreds of kilometers at least hundreds
of
under hundreds of miles you can have an
optical fiber where you shine
a light in at one end and you look at
the other end you can see the light at
the other end
and so that's the way that a large part
of the infrastructure of the internet is
built
is through optical fibers laid in tubes
in the ground or under oceans and things
um where they are uh whether where the
light is being shining at one end
and um it goes there it can be just a
single fiber that can go for a hundred
miles or more maybe these days
um and light comes out what happens at
the other end where you have to have a
repeater
where basically you have a receiver of
the light a thing that notices that
light's coming in
a photoelectric cell for example and
then when light comes in
then you for example have a laser that
uh
you know that produces a a pulse when
that light came in that's a repeater
so that even if the amount of light that
came in had gone down a bit
that laser is going to sort of refresh
that
and produce a nice a nice um a nice
pulse again
so that's kind of how how um a lot of
communication through
through light works in terms of of free
space communication with light which i
think was the original question
i don't think one sees that terribly
much um and i guess
that uh they're just a lot of things
that can sort of go wrong
when you have when you're just using a a
laser
to communicate with because it's like
anything that isn't transparent anything
that we can't see through
the light of visible light won't be able
to go through
with radio waves a bit different you
know with radio waves depending on the
frequency of the radio waves
you can have the radio waves go through
you know they go through windows they go
through
some kinds of walls they go through
other kinds of things
and also the another thing that happens
is
because of the because of the
frequencies of these things they can do
things like
um they can they can bend a little bit
when they go around things
through diffraction they can also get
reflected off lots of different kinds of
things
it's it's just a little bit easier to
get um uh to get the information
uh to get the radio waves to to to
propagate around it's a they act a
little bit more like sound waves i mean
if you're
if you're talking at one end of a
corridor or something
somebody can hear you around the corner
and that happens because of reflection
of the sound
diffraction of the sound and so on it's
a it's a little bit sort of fuzzier
than the then what happens usually with
light where it's a beam of light
and nothing sort of gets outside of that
beam you know with 5g
communications that's operating on
frequencies usually
that are somewhere between sort of the
most traditional radio frequencies and
frequencies the much higher frequencies
of light um it hasn't got quite that far
yet but
but there there's a lot of issues about
whether when you use a rep
this is for communication wirelessly um
the you know when you use a repeater how
many
uh weather things are line of sight
whether you can actually see from
from the transmitter to the receiver and
so on whether you have to be
bounce things off something and so on
anyway it's a that's a small um
uh a small uh
response there okay let's see
um we have a question
here
oh that's interesting okay there's a
question from ryan here
how can there be different kinds of
twilight
and would you observe the same thing on
mars
okay so if you go to wolfman alpha for
example and you say
when is sunset it's going to tell you
well the sunset is at this time
but there's also civil twilight nautical
twilight
astronomical twilight what are these
things
so okay first question is what is sunset
okay and uh well the earth is rotating
the question is where you're sit
standing on the earth
can you see the sun or not as the earth
rotates there'll come a moment when
you can't see the sun anymore and what
that looks like is
if you look at the sun in the sky the
sun will go down to the horizon and
eventually the sun will go below the
horizon
okay so one first question is can you
predict when that will happen well
obviously you know the rotation of the
earth
you do all kinds of astronomy and so on
but the precise question of when the sun
will go below the horizon is partly a
question of
was there a mountain in the way was
there a tree in a way
in the way how how high up were you were
you
at the top of a tall building were you
down on the ground
um you know all those kinds of questions
and the detailed geometry determines
exactly when the sun will seem to set
the other issue is that when light comes
to you from the sun
the light doesn't go exactly in a
straight line
light normally goes uh in okay this is
going to be a little bit complicated so
so let me let me just tell a little bit
of a story you know in wolfen alpha for
example we like to say the sunset is at
such and such a time
okay question is could we say when the
sunset is to the second
we can certainly say to the minute when
it is but can we say to the second one
it is
well it turns out it's very tricky to
say to the second when it is
what does it mean for the sun to have
set well it probably means that the disk
of the sun
which is you know the disc of the sun
might be about you know
angular size about you know the size of
your thumb held out at the end of your
arm type thing it's not it's not
a point so there isn't so you know it's
when the sunset might be when the top of
the disc of the sun
uh falls below the horizon okay so now
the question is
can we predict that precisely knowing
the rotation of the earth and all those
kinds of things
okay the answer is it's a little tricky
because of the phenomena
refraction uh same kind of thing that
gives you mirages and stuff like that
but but but
but what is refraction so
um when light
so normally light goes needless to say
at the speed of light if it's in a
vacuum
light goes exactly at the speed of light
but if light
is going through water or glass or some
other material
even though the material is transparent
and the light eventually gets out the
other end
the light doesn't go as quickly in those
materials what's happening
what's happening is in free space in a
vacuum
an electromagnetic wave is just the
essentially the photon is just
moving you can think of the light as
being made of a bunch of little photons
they're just moving at the speed of
light through the vacuum if they're in
a material like glass what's happening
is that's not what's going on
what's going on is that the photon is
being absorbed by an atom of glass
and then being re-emitted by that atom
of glass so it's kind of like the
repeater i was mentioning in fiber
optics
it's each the atoms in the glass are
acting like little repeaters they're
absorbing the photon
then they're re-emitting the photon
absorbing the photon re-emitting the
photon
they're doing that very very quickly but
it turns out they don't do it
instantaneously
it takes a little bit of time between
the time when the photon is absorbed and
the photon is being re-emitted
and so that means that the light goes
slightly slower
in glass or water or some other
transparent material than it does in a
vacuum
and the amount slower that it goes is
called the refractive index
and so for water for example the
refractive index is about 1.33
so that means light is going uh 33
slower in some sense in in water than it
is in
in a vacuum or in glass the refractive
index is usually between 1.5 1.7
um that kind of thing in a diamond the
refractive index is i believe 2.7
um so in a diamond light is going 2.7
times slower than it does
in in ordinary space if i remember the
refractive index correctly
um different things have different
refractive indices okay
so what is the significance of the
refractive index well that means that
um the one one
uh the one of the most important things
is
when light um light you have a light
beam coming in
it hits the surface of water for example
uh what happens
and you have to do a little bit of
geometry to understand why this happens
but
if the light is coming in at a certain
angle the
angle when the light goes into the water
the angle that the light goes at will be
slightly closer to vertical
than it was when the light was outside
of the water so in other words what it's
a thing called snell's law
and there's some trigonometry involved
although you can actually explain it
without trigonometry
um the sign of the angle is uh divided
by the refractive index basically when
when the sign of the angle of incidence
the angle between the vertical
and the the angle that the actual light
is going at
um but basically what happens is as as
light goes into this material it starts
going slower and in order for the light
not to kind of bunch up at the surface
of the material
you can kind of understand by by drawing
some diagrams
that it means the light has to go closer
to being vertical
than it did when it was coming from from
uh from the outside
so that's what happens with the with the
light from the sun when it goes through
the atmosphere when it goes through the
air
around the earth um the refractive index
of
of air is nothing like water 1.33
it's more like 1.00 and i don't remember
the number i could probably calculate it
um in um uh it's it's let's say it's
1.001
let's say let's say it's a thousandth of
a uh you know
um one one thousandth slower i don't
think that's right
i have to work it out um but it's
something roughly like that
um that light goes slower in air than it
does in vacuum
so the result of that is just like when
light goes into water
it goes a different angle same thing
when light comes from the sun
it's going to slightly different angle
when it comes into the atmosphere of the
earth
and so that change in angle means that
the precise moment when the sun is going
to go
below the horizon is determined depends
on
just exactly how much the um the light
was bent
by the um by refraction in the
atmosphere
and unless it gets even more complicated
because the amount of
the the refractive index of air depends
on the temperature of the air
and so that means that it depends was it
a hot day was it a cold day
was it hot in the uh in the upper part
of the atmosphere or not
when the light first started coming in
to the atmosphere and so on
so it's kind of complicated and that
means that there is a
a correction to the um uh to exactly
when the sun sets there a few seconds
whatever
that that is determined by those kinds
of things that's first statement
the second statement is even when the
sun has gone below the horizon
there is still okay this is this is
where again it's a little bit
complicated
okay let's let's start off with another
basic piece of physics
okay why is the sky not black
light from the sun is coming from a
particular direction that's where the
sun is
and the sun light from the sun is coming
from the sun to your eye
okay why is any of the rest of the sky
bright
in space it wouldn't be in space
black black sky there's some
uh you know there's the sun the sun is
is
is in a particular direction the sun is
very bright everything else is black
if you go high enough in the earth's
atmosphere you see the same thing
the one time i flew on the concord
airplane it flew at
60 000 feet maybe and that's high enough
that the sky was black
in the middle of the day which was kind
of cool but normally when the sun is out
so to speak the sky
the sky away from the sun is not black
it's
blue okay why is that happening
what's happening is that light from the
sun
in in space for example the only way
light from the sun comes to you is it
comes straight from the sun
to your eye but in the earth's
atmosphere what happens is there's light
coming from the sun to other places not
going straight towards you
but that it's it's going and hitting air
in the atmosphere
and that air is scattering the light so
what's happening is
just like what i was talking about when
light goes through glass or something
like this
the light is absorbed by an atom then
re-emitted by the atom
the exact same thing happens in the air
what happens is
the light is coming from the sun sun is
here
the light is is there's some piece of
air over here some molecule in the air
the light is is hitting that molecule
and the molecule
doesn't necessarily send the light out
only in the direction
that the light came in from the sun it
actually sends the light out in all
directions
at different rates in different
directions relative to where it came in
and so that means that even though the
the
light from the sun is coming only from
one direction when it's scattered
from a piece of air somewhere else the
light that came from the sun
is scattered in whatever direction and
then ends up coming to your eye
and so that's why what you're seeing and
the reason that um
uh that the sky is blue is that what's
happening is
that the blue light is more likely to be
scattered than red light
so you know light from the sun white
light roughly
it's a mixture of all the different
colors and uh
the different colors correspond to
different frequencies of photons and so
on
and what happens is blue light is
uh a slightly higher frequency higher
energy photons
and they are more likely to be scattered
by air molecules
than red light okay so what that means
is
that when the light from the sun that is
coming indirectly to you
from being scattered is more likely to
be blue than red and that's why the sky
looks blue
now the converse thing is when you're
looking at the sun
then light uh from that is if it's
red light is is um uh sorry blue light
is more likely to be scattered
that means the light that isn't
scattered is preferentially red
and that's why when you look at the sun
setting whether where the light from the
sun is coming through this
this sort of big column of air um the
that
it is more likely that blue light is
scattered away and so the sun
will look reddish as it sets okay but
this scattering phenomenon where
where the sun is um where you know light
is scattered in different directions
making the sky blue that same phenomenon
continues to happen
even when the sun is below the horizon
so if you
even that the sun is below the horizon
light from the sun is hitting an air
molecule
that is still that is not below the
horizon for you
and so you can see and so the light from
that air molecule
then gets scattered and you see it and
so the reason that the sky doesn't
immediately become completely
black when the sun sets is that
continues to be the scattering
phenomenon
much like the reason that the sky is
blue during the day
it's there's there's light that's being
scattered from
these uh from air molecules that still
can see the light of the sun
even because they're high up in the
atmosphere and your
and and that the light goes from the sun
to the air molecule
scattered from the air molecule comes to
you and that's why
it doesn't um that's why the sky doesn't
immediately become come completely dark
and these different levels of darkness
they usually i don't know i think that
they have different um
uh significance in terms of you know
when
um you know i think civil twilight is as
i
remember how these work but it's
probably when the street lights
are supposed to turn on and things and
maybe astronomical twilight is when
uh you know is when the sky is really
black um
and uh you can get your telescope out
and you're not going to be confused by
by having light from the sun and so on
um
and i think uh uh and there are no
doubts some sort of ways of of
characterizing these things about you
know nautical twilight is when
you can't see a ship on the ocean or
something i don't know
exactly how these things are defined now
there is some more stuff
that goes on there's a thing called
zodiacal light um
there's there's uh some more complicated
kinds of sky brightness at night
uh some more complicated sources of sky
brightness so for example one of them is
there is dust in our solar system and
that dust in our solar system even when
the
even when the sun is on the opposite
side of the earth
uh from you the sun can still illuminate
dust that's that's out in in the solar
system in the plane of the ecliptic in
the in the plane that the earth rotates
in around the sun
there's some dust there and that dust
will be
illuminated by the sun so the earth
might be here the
the sun is still illuminating that dust
and that dust is being lit
up and you're basically seeing light
scattered from that dust it's called
zodiacal light
and that's one of the things that leads
to a certain sky brightness
that happens um uh even when the sun is
is far below the horizon so to speak
um so that's a little bit on on uh
on how how twilight works
brian is saying sunset over the ocean
could be known to the second
um
hmm well that's an interesting
question so i i don't know how much it
depends on the refraction effects
i know that when we were when there was
a total solar eclipse that was visible
from the us
we made went to a lot of effort to try
and compute
uh to the second when the eclipse would
reach a particular point on the surface
that was hard to do but i think it
depended on the fact that in
a solar eclipse the sun is overhead the
sun is not going through a big column of
air
light from the sun is not going through
a big column of air and i think that has
more of an effect
we did manage to nail it to the second
we couldn't get it more accurate than a
second
um and it started to depend on all sorts
of detailed effects there
so let's see
um
let's see
um
wow lots of complicated questions here
um
okay there's a question here from uh
negatronotron um
what is the lowest energy anyone has
ever produced from electron positron
annihilation
and what range were they dropped into
each other
um not sure i can answer that question
um
completely uh so
reminder about these things electrons
smallest
uh particles that exist in atoms carry
electric charge
positrons are the anti-particles of
electrons that are exactly the same as
electrons except they have the opposite
electric charge
and when an electron positron i think i
talked about this another time when an
electron positron
are collide with each other they can
annihilate each other and produce
typically two photons sometimes three
photons or more photons
um so the question being asked is if you
have
um an electron and a positron and
they're just sort of being dropped
towards each other
how slowly could they be going so
electron and positron
have opposite electric charges so
they'll be pulled together
by electrical attraction
but what can happen is that they form a
thing called positronium
which is an atom where the in an
ordinary atom the nucleus of the atom
contains protons and neutrons
but there's a and then the ones going
around that nucleus so to speak
in positronium um it's kind of a weird
thing
you have a positron is the nucleus of
this sort of fake
atom and there's an electron going
around the positron
so you have this positronium is this
thing that has
a um that can be stable for quite a
while eventually
eventually it will decay into photons as
the electron and positron basically
uh interact with each other and
annihilate each other but so when you
form positronium
you can effectively the the slowest you
can get
an electron positron to be really near
each other is in the ground state of
positronium
um in other words the so so what happens
is
in according to quantum mechanics in an
atom uh there are
different discrete energy levels so in
other words an electron for example in a
hydrogen atom
an electron can either be at a certain
energy or it can be at a higher energy
or higher energy and there's a whole
series of these
these energy levels and eventually when
this when the when the uh
electron has too much energy it will
escape the hydrogen atom it will escape
the proton that's the nucleus
the hydrogen atom will become ionized
and the electron will just go off
separately
with positronium there's again a
sequence of energy levels just like
there is in a hydrogen atom
and the lowest of those energy levels is
the energy level
at which which is the the sort of the
lowest state
that um that the electron can exist um
according to quantum mechanics it can't
have a lower energy in
in a positronium um atom and i do not
know what the lowest energy
uh state in positronium is
let me think about this for a second can
i calculate it
non-trivial real-time quantum
electrodynamics computation i don't
think i can do it
um
let's see we need to know
for a hydrogen atom uh the
energy relative to the free electro free
proton and free electron
is 13.6 milliliter 13.6 electron volts
um all right ah i'm i'm sorry i can't
remember all these numbers
um and uh i i think i'm not going to be
super boring and try and do a a
real-time quantum electronics
computation
and i i'm really bad at doing these
computations like
in my head i really need to be typing on
a computer
and um uh and that's going to to break
the flow of all this
so that's as good as i can as as i can
get there
um it's a question from dba
druid that's a cool name how do i become
a scientist like you
and uh how did you
make it to create a business out of it
well um
you know how do you become a scientist
i think in the best case first you have
to be interested in doing it
uh you know i think that that what what
do
scientists do for a living what do they
actually do
well the thing that many scientists like
most to do i think most scientists like
most to do
is research figuring out new things
taking some question about the world
about
some scientific question and figuring
out the answer to that question
but often in the practical doing of
science there's a lot of other
stuff that goes around that you have to
describe to other people
you know yes you should pay for my
equipment to go and
investigate this question yes i figured
out this cool thing let me explain it to
you
all those kinds of things there's quite
a lot that goes into doing science
that isn't just the figuring out the
answer to the question
now how do you figure out the answer to
the question different scientists have
very different ways of doing that
some people will a lot of the time
you're you're doing uh you're you're
you're just
doing sort of uh taking steps to use
tools to make small progress towards
answering the question
and occasionally there's a like aha i
get it now i really understand
and um i would say that for me at least
it's um the process of using tools
doing examples making doing little
experiments i always do them on
computers
rather than physical experiments um that
process
is the main thing that sort of takes the
time in doing science
and that process is what
for me at least allows me to sort of
develop intuition and understand things
to the point where occasionally i'll say
aha i get what's going on now i
understand how to make some kind of
conceptual leap
how do you get to the point of being
able to do those kinds of things
i think one very important thing
probably two important things
maybe maybe more but two important
things are
know facts about science and be good at
using tools
that let you uh figure out things that
haven't been figured out before
you know knowing facts about science if
you're going to do science
it's really useful um you can and people
have a habit
of learning these microscopic you know
just
very very very specific facts about this
very specific area that is not usually
the most productive thing to do i mean
insofar as i've made progress in in
doing things in science
very very very often it's like there's
this thing that comes from over here
there's this thing that i learned about
in some completely other context from
over here
and the thing that i managed to do is to
realize ah these are basically the same
thing or they're closely connected
let's pull these things together and
then we can make progress
and um that's um so knowing a lot of
stuff about science is really useful
i mean for me i'm i have a hard time
learning things i'm not interested in
and um uh so you know what tends to
happen is i'll learn about scenario of
science because i'm interested in that
specific area
because i'm interested in answering some
particular question in that area
and i won't learn about some other area
because just not that interested in it
if i try and sort of force feed myself
the area that i'm not interested in read
some book about it or something
i usually have a hard time with that i'm
not you know my one of my personal
failings were not particularly good at
that
other people can usually what i find is
if there's an
area where for whatever reason i really
want to
make a contribution to that area i
really want to figure something out in
that area
another thing i found is even an area
that i thought oh that's completely
boring there's nothing to say about that
as soon as you really dive into it you
realize actually
there's some pretty interesting
questions here and there really are
things which
i'd be curious about and then i'm off
and running and exploring that area
but if i try and without sort of that
step if i'm just like oh i should learn
about this for the sake of learning
about it
i for example find that pretty hard to
do in terms of tools
you know i've spent much of my life
building tools to let me and lots of
other people
do science as efficiently as possible
and that's the whole world from language
mathematica
or from alpha story of sort of building
this computational language
that allows you to to sort of make
computational the things that you're
thinking about and trying to make
progress and in science
and when i sort of do science i'm
typically doing it
typing things to a wolfram language
notebook and you know and getting
results from that
um and i would say that that being a
you know knowing those tools well is
super super useful
and it's kind of a a superpower for
doing science in today's world i mean
and eventually everybody will know that
stuff really well
um the the best scientists like in
you know in in most areas actually you
know i run into them and it's like i
didn't know you you know they
turns out they've used wall from
language for 20 years and i didn't know
you
knew that and then it turns out you look
at their code it's actually quite good
it's um you know it's it's quite they're
like they really got it they understood
how to do things
they use it as a tool that lets them
really really make
make progress and that's a really
worthwhile thing as i say
for now it's a superpower um in the
future it won't be i mean it's just like
at one time
if you knew calculus that was a
superpower in doing certain kinds of
mathematical sciences
because only very few people or fairly
few people knew it at this point if
you're going to go into various kinds of
mathematical sciences
you're going to be fed calculus at some
point you know everybody's going to
learn it but for right now
you know learning kind of work from
language and so on and learning it well
not just roughly but learning it well
and the way to learn it well
is to actually try and solve problems
with it things that you're interested in
and figure out how to do those that's
the way to learn it well
and that's that's a really important and
useful skill now in terms of
of uh kind of what it takes to
sort of do be to do useful things in
science
i would say that that those two things
no facts
get be good at the tools those are those
are really important
but the thing that is really the
determiner typically of how
uh sort of important the science you're
going to be able to do will tend to be
is usually do you ask the right
questions that is
that there's so you need the facts you
need the the tools
the mechanical ability so to speak but
you also need to know
what's a worthwhile thing to ask about
what's a worthwhile thing to think about
um and i would say that the main way
that you get to be able to
do that is just by doing it
just by saying well you know i hear
about this thing
maybe even some crazy thing i mentioned
here might be interesting
it's like i wonder how that really works
you know i wonder
what the real story with that is well go
look up what the story is
then go say well i wonder if you could
do this or that or the other
okay now go figure that out it's the i
wonder whether
etc etc etc that leads to
kind of coming up with good science now
now for me
you know i've tended to notice that uh
you know
the best questions are the most
fundamental questions the best questions
are the
sometimes the most obvious questions and
the mistake
not to make is oh that's an obvious
question somebody must have answered it
uh it's amazing how common it is that
you'll find a field of science
where if you say what's the most obvious
question okay here it is
okay what's has somebody answered it
maybe yes maybe no
maybe it's 50 chance either way um but
it's not the case just because it was an
obvious question it's been answered
now sometimes the obvious question uh
that hasn't been answered is really hard
to answer
um but often even the idea that you're
going to try and pick away that the
at the fundamental really obvious
question you can get a lot of mileage by
doing that
and if you say well let's look at what
other people have done
in doing this kind of science oh they're
working on this little microscopic
question over here in this corner
and that must be the kind of thing you
can do in the science that's not true
it's often the case that the big
questions nobody looked at them
and sometimes with new methods that you
can bring with news you know
tools type superpowers that you have you
can make progress on those questions
even though you know it seemed like oh
those must be really hard because
otherwise everybody would have worked on
them
it's amazing how rarely people work on
the fundamental questions in particular
fields
now in terms of uh you asked also about
businesses based on science
you know i've been lucky enough to find
a way to take things that i find
intellectually interesting
and to map them into things that seem to
be useful to the world so to speak
and that you can make businesses out of
i mean for me
it's uh i kind of backed into 40 years
ago now
uh starting my first company and so on i
was sort of an academic before that
um young academic um and
in um i would say that
it is a very fortunate case when the
things that you find intellectually
interesting
are close to things which are
immediately indirectly useful i mean
i've been working on the fundamental
theory of physics
uh recently and while that is highly
interesting
on the face of it it's not directly
related
to anything here and now that's turning
out that to my great surprise
the fundamental theory of physics is
leading us
to methods that are absolutely relevant
to things here and now about distributed
computing
generalizations of blockchain all kinds
of other things
which are very much here and now kinds
of questions i wasn't expecting that i
was thinking
that it would be uh something where it
was of great intellectual interest but
not really
connectable to the here and now now of
course there's a little bit of
the okay you could do the fundamental
theory of physics in a way that was
fundamentally
unconnectable to the here and now and
the fact is that
perhaps because i know a certain amount
about distributed computing i know a
certain amount of blockchain
it's like when i see there's this thing
where it's oh my gosh
there is this possible connection i can
actually follow up on that because i
have
you know content knowledge of those
areas and it's not like
it's not like i don't notice when the
thing that is showing up
is just like the issues that come up in
distributed blockchain for example
so that's some but in terms of the of
the practicality of
sort of being a scientist so to speak um
the uh it depends on what stage of life
you're at
um i would say learning the tools
learning facts highly important
you know ask questions try and um
for me it's very useful to try and do
the kind of thing i'm doing right now
explain stuff to people i find that a
great way to actually understand things
myself and it's a great kind of
discipline of knowing that i actually
understand something is can i really
explain it to people
um so having an opportunity to do that
writing things about the things you do
those kinds of things those are those
are super worthwhile
i mean i i would mention actual
resources like we have a
uh a summer camp for high school
students we have a summer school for
grown-ups we have all kinds of things
like this that are that are at least
ways of
of introducing people to the kind of
thinking that that um
uh that i've spent a large part of my
time um
learning how to do let's see
there's a question here oh gosh so many
questions
question from mikhail is it possible to
do phd a
phd research under my supervision i've
been kind of out of that business for a
long time
but um we have a mechanism for our
physics project for example
uh where we have just built this
collection of research affiliates
and junior research affiliates the
junior research affiliates
are people who are students of various
kinds who we are
trying to provide some sort of framework
um
and resources and community uh for those
people to work on things
um we're we're not solving the problem
right now
of oh you know where are you going to
get funding for your phd from
um that's a different that's a different
factor problem we are providing however
the mechanism of um uh of um
um of of um uh of
providing sort of a advice and
supervision for for content kinds of
things and um
uh that's something where i'm i'm trying
to inject myself in the most useful
possible way
and it's kind of something i've learned
from running companies for a long time
is it's not the case that you know the
ceo is the right person
to have every discussion about every
every detail of every topic
uh that would not be a scalable or
useful thing to do
uh the question is can you inject
yourself at the time when there's a
critical decision to be made
in the case of research can you sort of
inject yourself at the moment when
there's a key sort of uh thing to be
figured out
um and then can you provide sort of uh
sort of resources derived from what you
do that uh that work for other in other
places so so we do have a framework for
that and and
uh if you're interested in that um uh
please
be in touch with us um
the uh um
let's see oh boy we've got lots of
things here all right
let's try a few things here all right
i'm going to try from enrico
uh can photons interact i've heard
of light by light scattering
uh but aren't photons independent
quantum activations or electromagnetic
waves okay
let me try this for a second um
so if you have a laser shine a laser in
some direction
your sign will shine a laser in another
direction that crosses that first laser
beam
the two laser beams won't they won't
have any effect on each other
to a very good approximation light just
passes straight through light
it's unlike material objects where if
you have uh
you know a jet of gas or something you
have another jet of gas
and and the the molecules from one jet
of gas will
will collide with the molecules from
other jet of gas and they'll get
scattered around
and and you know it'll be a different
thing but with light
as far as one knows you know in a first
approximation
light just goes straight through light
um
now light is a is a
if you had a gravity wave turns out that
doesn't happen gravity waves interact
with each other
so gravitons do interact graviton to
graviton so to speak
but photons don't interact directly
photon to photon
um so the reason so the question then is
how can
do photons have any effect on each other
well there's a slightly obscure
phenomenon it's a piece of quantum
electrodynamics
that's called light by light scattering
and so roughly what happens is this
the um uh uh
boy this is a little challenging okay so
in in the world of content
electrodynamics i'll say what the um
uh what the official version of this is
and then i'll try and explain it
so light by light scattering is the
result of a thing called box diagram
a feminine diagram and what it is is you
have basically two photons come in
they're going to be the two photons are
going to be scattered the two photons uh
produce an electron positron pair they
produce
an electron and a positron but these are
virtual electron positron pair
which then annihilate again to produce
two other photons
and so in a sense what's happening in
light by light scattering is
two photons are coming in they're
turning into an electron positron pair
for a very brief period of time
and then they're turning back into two
photons and the way you perceive that
is just oh the two photons had some
interaction they scattered
but that's the mechanism underneath by
which the scattering occurred
and um the uh the thing that um
um you uh so so that phenomenon
happens but it happens it happens very
rarely
and the higher the energy of the photons
the more likely it is to happen
as the energy of the photons gets to be
comparable to the mass of the electron
that's that's uh very high energy gamma
rays the chance of this light by light
scattering increases dramatically
so for ordinary light the um uh the the
scattering of light by light for just an
ordinary laser beam is infinitesimally
small
the uh in roughly i think if i remember
correctly the um uh
the amount of uh the the probability of
scattering of light by light
increases with it as the eighth power of
the energy of the photons
so it's a very um uh it's it increases
uh is very small for a long time
when you get to really high energy
photons
um colliding really high energy photons
and it's possible to do that in particle
accelerators
you can essentially have uh photon
photon interactions
when the energy of the photons is high
enough you can produce all kinds of
particles and you can get all kinds of
complicated things
um but at ordinary energies like like
for an ordinary light beam
um that's that's roughly how it works
um
let's see uh
a lot of questions about physics theory
i think it's time for me to do another
session about um about the physics
theory
um
somebody is commenting it's hydrogen
divided by
two that is probably my question about
the lowest energy of positronium and i
think you
are right because yes
yes i think you're right it's just a
question of where the center of mass of
the
of the uh of the thing is yup i think
you're right
um let's see
um
um
um
uh there's a question about postdocs you
should um
get in touch with us from the through
the physics project website
um that's the best uh or if you're
interested in other kinds of
computational things through the company
um there's a question here which is more
of a general um
um okay there's a couple of questions
okay i'm going to try a couple more and
then we should wrap up for today
um a question from a toure it says my
supervisor says i should do
little small projects and publish lots
um
but uh a person says i'm more inclined
to do deeper
fewer deeper works what should you do
i would say if you're a young person
just getting started
uh a a large number of small things is
better
than uh sort of one very deep thing
because if you've never done it before
it's really difficult doing a big deep
project
and the trick is to do those
comparatively small projects but to make
them
to not make them be each one should
be interesting okay here's a general
idea for sort of okay
the more obvious the question you're
answering is the more likely it is
people are going to care about your
answer so
if you're working in some area of
science and the shortest description you
can give of what you're doing
is a paragraph long it's probably
the set of people who are going to care
is is considerably smaller
if on the other hand the thing you can
uh that you're talking about is
something where you say
the question is blah blah blah blah and
it's a it's you know one or two sentence
thing that you're describing that's
likely to be something of more general
interest it's likely to be something
where more people are going to
care about it it's a good thing um so i
think that
but it doesn't need to be the case that
just because it's an obvious question
and you know it doesn't need to be a
question that
that has to have the biggest deepest
answer um
it's it's like if you can answer that
the obvious question it's already very
useful
even though the answer may not be all
that deep and i think it is
it's it's it's really difficult to do a
big project i mean
when i started off doing science i i
published my first paper when i was
maybe 15 years old or something
and it wasn't particularly good my first
one but by the time my second and third
papers
were significantly better um and uh
the um but they were you know
modest sized things and and over time
i got to the point where i like to make
papers that were definitive for whatever
they were about so even though the
question might not be this giant deep
question
at least for the particular question i
would just get everything out of that
question
and just answer it nail it and that
turns out to be a pretty useful thing to
do that people
sort of continue caring about decades
later and i think that um
uh you know doing a really big project
to projects can take multiple years
etc etc etc i i think very few people
can do that
successfully without having a fair
amount of experience and the way you get
experience is by doing smaller projects
now you know small doesn't mean
kind of super specialized and you know
description is six paragraphs long
uh small just means it's not
doing something like inventing the whole
fundamental theory of physics
that's a big difficult project it's not
doing something
like i don't know building a
you know a giant computational language
that's 50 million lines of code
and etc etc etc um it means
it's studying i don't know a particular
thing i was just studying with something
which actually people could have studied
anytime in the last 2000 years
i was studying the empirical
meta-mathematics of euclid
which i'll hopefully be writing about so
early next week
um it's a you know that was actually for
me i thought this is going to be a super
easy project it's only going to take a
few days actually taking more like a
couple of weeks
um and turned out to be pretty
interesting um but uh you know that's a
project
that i think one could do it you know i
don't
hopefully i've done it decently well but
but it probably doesn't need my whole
experience base to be able to do that
project it's a comparatively
small well-defined project but you know
for me
i started off doing much smaller
projects and i gradually over the course
of about a decade
got to the point where i was doing
bigger and bigger projects to the point
where i've been doing absurdly large
projects
and you know uh having learned how to do
absurdly large projects you
learn a certain rhythm of how to do
these things um
that uh uh that lets you get through it
i mean the biggest project biggest
single project i've done was probably
writing my
new kind of science book which took
about 10 years and
uh it was just as well i didn't have to
explain to anybody what i was really
doing for those 10 years because
you know if i was like uh had been
working at a university or something
people say what the heck are you doing
it's like well i'm doing this big
project uh really what
you know what is it all about well okay
it's a you know i can describe that one
sentence what it's about you know
exploring the computational universe
of simple programs and and what the
significance of that is but in more
detail
there's just a huge amount to say so i
would say that it's not bad advice
to to do um uh uh you know
doesn't mean do super specialized but it
does mean don't do projects that are
going to take
you know a year or two to do two
projects that it didn't take a month or
two to do
um it's a question here
um that's actually
somebody was commenting the truth is we
still have a nice answer but i'm not
sure what that was an answer
to um
uh oh i see it's a question about
gravity i i should
i should cover that a different
different time um
there's a comment here
um okay
uh all right i'll try one more from
cybot um
is there a hard lesson that you've
learned
that impacted you deeply i don't know
i've had a
i've had a fairly i i'm happy to say i
haven't had a
um uh i
you know i've i've had a life where i've
mostly been able to do stuff i've wanted
to do and
you know things have worked out decently
well and that's good
and and um uh not a lot of
a lot of trauma i'm happy to say now to
some extent one makes one's own fate
and uh you know part of the reason for
that is that i've chosen to do things
that are a fairly good match for me and
i've not chosen to do things
um that um are um
uh um uh you know where where
they're unsuitable for me i noticed some
somebody on live stream commenting
10 years working on the same project is
is um an amazing thing
it is it's a it's a that's a good
example of a um
uh i mean i was frankly proud of my
tenacity in managing to get through a
project that took 10 years to do
i mean in a sense for example building
wall from language i've been doing that
for 33 years now
but that's a project that involves a lot
of other people and it has a lot of
different pieces of of in the in the
rhythm of that project it's not just one
of these
i gotta dig in and do the same thing for
a long time
um yes it takes uh i mean i would say
that the
my feeling about my personal tenacity um
being able to get through a 10-year
project yeah i've definitely got a
certain amount of personal tenacity
and that is necessary to do such a thing
um
and uh you know i think the big
achievement of that project was to
finish it
there are people that unfortunately i
know who've sort of had i've got this
great big project and
20 years 30 years goes by and you kind
of know they're never going to finish it
which is kind of sad
in a sense my physics project recently
was almost an example of that i had
started working on the things that have
led to this
theory 30 years ago started i stopped
i started i stopped again i kind of
stopped about uh
16 years ago uh because i wasn't
uh for various reasons i've described
elsewhere but um
uh the you know i almost didn't get to
do that project and actually the very
fact that i've now been able in the last
year
to jump in and uh and and do this
project and it's worked out really great
and it's you know it's still got lots
lots of distance to go but it's
working out really great that frankly is
a tremendous encouragement to me
to go do a bunch of other big difficult
projects that i've meant to do
for decades and i've like am i going to
get round to this
well the answer is yes i'm going to do
it
you know a bit more than a year ago i
said i'm going to try and um
uh undo this physics project and i'm
like
i'm really going to do it this is my
chance this is you know
let me i've got a couple of young people
who are really enthusiastic about
working on it
um you know let's just try and do it and
now i'm encouraged to try and do other
such projects
but um a question here was a hard lesson
that um impacted me i i would say that
the main
the main lesson is um do things that are
a good fit for one to do
i mean occasionally i try and do things
that
are not particularly good fits i mean
less so in recent years because i've
learned myself better
but an example i am back in the early
1980s
i worked hard in a bunch of science
about
how complexity arises in nature worked
really well
figured out a lot of really interesting
science i thought
this is a great field for lots of other
people to get involved in let's create a
field complexity theory
complex systems research whatever you
call it let's create this field
and let's go make this happen in the
world
well uh i think i was pretty good at
doing the science
i think i was even pretty good at
leading other people
if they wanted to do the science but
this phenomenon
of kind of organizing the world so that
something would happen
is not my forte and what i realized
is you know i i didn't waste a huge
amount of time but i wasted a certain
amount of time
on uh you know going around figuring out
the best university to start a research
institute at to do this kind of stuff
and then
realizing and then i kind of realized
this isn't what i want to do i mean i
you know i can go raise money for other
people to do this research but that's
completely not what i'm interested in
doing if i'm going to be involved
the main part of what i'm interested in
is being involved in
is actually doing the research not
convincing other people to give money to
other people to do the research type
thing
so that was an example of something
where i i kind of tried it
and i realized this is not for me this
is not what i'm good at
you know let me not do this um and that
was
that was a useful thing to discover i
mean i would say that there are other
situations that i've been in where
where for me everybody is different for
me
you know i i uh i don't mind leading
things i'm i'm happy to lead things
and uh i don't get sort of uh i'm you
know i make decisions
some people are like oh my gosh what
decision should i make you know might be
i'll make the wrong decision and so on
uh maybe it's arrogance maybe it's
confidence maybe it's by this point some
experience
that uh you know i'm just like i'll make
the decision let's just move on
make decisions you know right before
this uh this
episode today i was doing some you know
spend an hour make a whole bunch of
decisions about things
um i find that pretty easy i don't get
stressed by it other people
find that very stressful and i'm much
happier in a situation where
it's like you know decisions are being
made for them so to speak and they're
being
you know they're working with other
people to make a consensus decision
those things drive me crazy and whenever
i'm in those situations
i'm like uh oh my gosh this is not for
me and i get very
um uh just horrible match and so those
are things where
you know i i've learnt for me i avoid
those
for other people they may be the right
thing and it's
it's some uh you know so i suppose the
the um uh
um that's probably uh one thing i mean i
i think there are other
there are other things like like for
example you do a big project
okay how long is going to take well
hard to know very rarely okay so when i
get into these projects like the 10-year
project i mentioned i didn't think it
was going to take 10 years
if i'd said at the beginning this is
going to be a 10-year project
it's like do i really want to do a
10-year project do i want to go from age
32 to age 42 doing this project
you know hmm difficult decision
probably yeah probably no let's not do
it so
you know there's a certain amount of
optimism that i for example will always
have going into these projects of look
i can see my way through this project
how long can it possibly take
and um that's a thing where where
you know i think that that term the one
example of a project
where i don't really think that hard
these days about how long is the project
going to take
because if i do it can't end well it's
like either it's going to take a really
really long time
and then i maybe i'm not going to do it
or i'm going to come up with a it's
going to take
three months and it takes much longer
and i'm all upset because it didn't take
the right amount of time
so i don't i don't tend to think
internally too much about that question
i'm just like
is this project a project i want to do
yes okay great let's do it
um you know the physics project that
we've done
uh frankly it got to where it got to
it's one of the only projects i've ever
done
major projects that worked more quickly
than i expected
i think i was pretty efficient in my
part of what i was doing there
but it was a project that sort of really
exceeded my expectations and was faster
than expected
um i think i'm trying to remember and
i'm thinking
there's some better response to this
question of
of um um
hard lessons i i don't know i've i've um
um
i've uh uh
you know it's a funny thing because i've
done bunch of projects in my life
i think it's fair to say that that
essentially no major project i've done
has ever sort of outright failed
um and the um
uh you know why is that
you know is that because i'm so good at
doing these projects or is that for some
other reason i think there's a different
reason
first i haven't i've been fairly you
know not completely stupid in the
projects i've picked
but second of all when the projects are
in progress so to speak it's like
sometimes you realize
the direction we're going in that's not
quite the right direction let's make a
little mid course correction
and what would have turned into a
failure if you just
insisted on just walking straight
forward in that direction
uh turned into a success because you
just made this small turn
in the intermediate stage where you to
get to a slightly different target
because you realize the first target
wasn't right i think
um you know it's it's a um
uh this question of of look i mean there
are other pieces that i could expound on
um about sort of uh um
uh you know another thing that i happen
to
uh be big on is sort of
uh um uh sort of do the right thing
and sort of uh you know act with
integrity even if it's harder to do at
the time
uh because that's a that's a that's a
great way to keep your life simple
not locally simple it's often locally
much more complicated
to do the right thing but in a global
scale
i must say that i have found it in my
life watching other people where they
don't do that
you know it's like oh my god you get
into all this trouble with this and that
and the other and it's
it's all very complicated and so on and
it's just like
just sort of try and do the right thing
now sometimes it's not easy to figure
out what is the right thing
and you have to kind of zoom out a bit
and try and say what are the principles
that you want to follow you know
how should you treat people what should
you do with this or that
how you know it's uh but you know you
zoom out a bit you realize what the
answer is
and even if it's a little bit more
effort because you've got to explain
to somebody why this or that thing that
everybody thought was the right thing to
do really isn't the right thing to do
and so on and people are like
oh no that's wrong and you know there's
a lot of flapping about it and so on
um you know at least i've found it's one
way of
avoiding certain kinds of issues is sort
of just
try and do the right thing i would say
that the same is true
look when you build technology when you
do science there's
somewhat the same kind of thing happens
it's like you build a piece of
technology do you do it right
or do you do it uh in a way that is
like oh i'm just gonna hack something
together and it'll be you know
that's what i'll do now you know it's
complicated because you can say i'll do
it right but it's gonna take me five
years
by which point the world isn't going to
care it's not going to be the right time
etc etc etc so that's another
complicated thing is that you have to
decide
you know do it right with respect to the
thing you're trying to achieve
which might not be sort of the thing you
build for the ages so to speak
anyway okay before i get too much more
into into personal philosophy kinds of
things although i am happy to talk about
those types of things
if people find that interesting um but i
signed up here for science and
technology q a rather than
personal philosophy though i'm happy to
talk about personal philosophy
um i'm not sure that um
and we should probably
wrap up for today and um
thank you very much for for coming and
um uh you know i i don't know whether we
have a good mechanism for
getting feedback about some these events
but um
uh you know i've been doing this for a
while i started doing this when the
pandemics started
um and uh i've been having fun hopefully
people have been finding these
interesting
um but it's one of these other
mid-course corrections we should be
making
um i am seeing quite a lot of questions
here that are more advanced
um uh science questions as i say i think
i should do another
uh q a about our physics project um
uh where we can talk about more advanced
uh technical kinds of things
um and uh i'm also um happy to take
suggestions
um about uh other things people might
find useful or interesting
um uh the um
uh you know i find this fun so
hope you like it too and uh hope to see
you again um
uh next um uh next time or another time
and yes we should set up some kind of
form to um
uh to get uh to get input for this
okay thanks a lot